we were talking about this we were
sitting there I don't know how this came
up in a conversation going oh man that
was a great film you couldn't make that
nowadays how often do you say that to
yourself
I think I'm guessing probably pretty
often pretty often probably pretty often
so we actually decided to and you've
been tweeting us will will read them
after this segment we decided to put
together a segment here a definitive
list we'll be updating it the top five
films that you couldn't make in 2016
let's do it
[Music]
for reasons that are self-explanatory
they would be far too triggering yes so
a lot of these you'll notice some trends
here let's get right into it number five
is a bit of an obvious one not without
my daughter
now a lot of Millennials watching her
what's that this is a film made with
Sally Field I want to say in the early
90s about a woman who married a Muslim
they go to Iran and obviously he keeps
the daughter beats the hell out of some
women she finds out with his Islamic
family kind of help this happens a lot
by the way people make their pilgrimage
either they're going to Mecca secular
Westerners they marry these Muslims and
they've signed up for and they can't get
their kids back we had Q on the show
remember the woman who had actually
suffer in the United States now yeah
these people
I think Alfred Molina Sally Field I'm
sure they're probably at hashtag on with
her they're probably to the left but
back then because it hadn't been
politicized the Islamic mistreatment of
women the Islamic basically complete
disregarding of women's rights
it was just seen as a human rights issue
it wasn't seen as a xenophobia or
political issue people weren't afraid to
speak out against it including liberals
because it was just like don't wear fur
it was just an issue you shouldn't beat
women and this is a real problem in the
Middle East and this is a problem with
Islam and at that point it wasn't the
cause du jour
so even left to spec then felt okay
doing it you could not do this nowadays
here's a clip to show you what I'm
talking about
Oh John Cena honor
I mean hook on that guy hook doc ock got
some punch
she had it coming number four Dirty
Harry we're coming in here I think a lot
of people talk about this a lot of
people have actually suggested the one
that is actually number two coming up
soon Dirty Harry's is actually more so
the franchise we came up with this we
were thinking play misty for me then we
thought sudden impact and the reason was
because women get the crap beaten out of
them Clint Eastwood punch his woman
right in the face including afro and
hookers and then we realize he does that
and pretty much every film but Dirty
Harry you see a lot of it here's
something that's also really important
Dirty Harry not only the sexist stuff
you know sort of insensitive stuff that
you couldn't do nowadays you'd be called
into HR but the concept of Dirty Harry
was coming after a crime wave in the in
the 60s and in the 70s where people felt
really unsafe and Dirty Harry was a
police officer who didn't play by the
rules who would definitely be rough
around the edges but got stuff done he
was a hero it's the exact opposite of
the black lives matter thing right now
if this were happening today Dirty Harry
would instead of shooting the rapist in
the street he would be wearing a body
camera taking him in for questioning and
bringing in his lawyer with a lot of
vowels in his name and then eventually
letting him free so it's not just the
insensitivities but the the concept of
Hardy Harry would not work today which I
think you're seeing that a little bit
with Trump people wanted a Dirty Harry
they want a strong man to come back when
they felt disenchanted I think so
stripped of power this clip captures the
chauvinism perfectly and what the hell
gives you the right to become an
inspector when there's men have been out
there on the street for 10 or 15 years
woman's place is in the home is that
what you're trying to say you don't
think this is some kind of encounter
group I want to know what officer Moore
is gonna do when somebody puts a gun at
her and says hit the deck you son of a
[ __ ] she's going to cower that's what
most women do or they just get hit in
the head with a snare drum number three
Animal House yes now I know what you're
thinking is this because it was too
profane and because no none of that
actually it's not even because it's a
bromance it's not even because it's just
it's you know they need to recast it
today with women I guess it kind of did
that with neighbors too sorority rising
he was horrendously unfunny
but Animal House some scenes in there
the kind of scenarios that give Lena
Dunham and Amy Schumer nightmares this
you realize when you watch Animal House
to me what's so telling is it started
off from the college culture it was
assumed that people just have drunken
sexual encounters that's a big thing
that happens in college
now again most of these people in that
film probably pretty pretty liberal
today
not not Matheson R he's doing something
just talk about how you liked Reagan but
it wasn't even considered a sexist it
wasn't considered a social issue that
kids have drunk sex in college nobody
would have even considered the idea that
two people who are both drunk who had
consensual intimate relations would be
considered rape now when you watch this
film you can find at least four or five
instances that would be a salon article
oh gosh
I think this captures it
[Music]
I knew a girl in high school who stuffed
her bra really yeah they just one time
she bore the chicken cutlets guess where
nickname was cutlets number two blazing
pythons number one they probably thought
so what do you think we'll be number one
tweet mate s Crowder or tweet him at not
gay Jerrod it might surprise you Blazing
Saddles this could have this could have
taken up spots a five through one now
this one is not as much the theme like
not without my daughter or Dirty Harry
because there isn't a whole bunch of
social commentary in the same way it is
just Mel Brooks at his best and
everything about this film is offensive
everything about it is it racist yes
homophobia it's got that sexist
absolutely xenophobia that wasn't even a
thing back then but sure let's go figure
it out they figured it out it was a
movie Blazing Saddles I think the reason
people love it so much is because it was
a film that could only be made at that
time yep
by Mel Brooks mm-hmm III don't know that
if they did remake it today the n-word
would not make an appearance you know
and it's in Django is jingle and chain
is not the same thing no Django
Unchained is not the same thing because
Quentin Tarantino is a far leftist and
it is kind of providing time and it's a
drama it's not the same thing this was
just throwing caution to the wind as
racist as offensive in everyone
apologetically so College ethically it's
why in back then it here's the thing
nobody had to start a march over it no
nobody for a second thought that Mel
Brooks was a racist think about it he
had the cast all the black people for
the black people to be treated in a
racist way they love Mel Brooks not a
person at a pedestal walk out and look
at it at himself I don't know people
said to that for radio I hope we know I
don't we don't we didn't say it just
drag up her corpse and hit her with the
fine uh-huh I don't think we have to say
any more about that if you haven't seen
it go see it number one
number one was gonna be fire this was a
tough one we thought we could go Tutsi
because it was before mrs. Doubtfire
Dustin Hoffman but the reason we picked
mrs. Doubtfire is because it's pretty
recent really do you think about it in
the in the span of we grew up with this
movie we grew up with this film and
here's what's important about mrs.
Doubtfire if you look at the film I mean
for those who don't know Robin Williams
plays a woman becomes a woman in order
to become a nanny and spend time with
his children it was pretty pretty
progressive for its time if you look at
it you know it was in San Francisco his
brother was gay it's certainly at that
time was normalizing gay relationships
in a way that you didn't see in a lot of
films it was making it very playful it
certainly wasn't anti gay but even the
gay characters in this film mocked the
transsexual situation even the gay
characters who call themselves Queens
and a professional makeup artists laugh
about a man wanting to become a woman
because even in the gay community was
just considered silly and absurd of
course you can't become a woman of
course this is funny of course this is
silly
of course it's abnormal so the film
great film by the way I think Robin
Williams Oh is one of the best dramatic
actors ever I think this is the kind of
film he where he was perfect funny but
with heart could just rip your heart out
of your chest kind of like a Ricky
Gervais Steve Carell there some
comedians were so good at making you
feel empathy and I think Robin Williams
was one of the best but it's again to
starting off point kind of like Animal
House or not without my daughter the
starting off point was that of assumed
abnormality with a man acting like a
woman and that was okay and it wasn't
considered hate speech and this was not
that long ago so nowadays when people
say what why he's still hateful we hate
speech if you say well actually you're
boring you're born a boy or a girl
imagine these script writers back then
with mrs. Doubtfire imagine them with
slate Salon Daily Kos HuffPo there's no
way this film could be made including by
liberals that set out to be pro gay to
be pro progressive they would have been
eaten alive here's a good clip to convey
what I'm talking about
oh man half woman
what what what half man half woman they
say get stay back pervert stay back
later in there which is this so
perfectly this is innocent it's not
hateful at all but of course it's crazy
of course at seven a little man dressed
as a woman as always it's always gonna
everything in your blood says this is
not natural it's like seeing an animal
flash red in the kingdom like oh my god
that's poison I shouldn't touch that bad
so send me your tweets at s Crowder and
what do you think should be added to the
list this has been this has been top 5
movies you couldn't make
what's that sound it's the sound of you
subscribing otherwise I'm going to send
anthrax to your house there's a button
below where you can click my face to go
to la tour with creditor calm or click
one of the videos playing next to me I
think there might be a mystery box what
could it be
and racks